good divert take a look at your green 20  feet underwater coastguard divers are  trying to check the props and rudder for  damage hey red turn to your left  but one of them is caught on the ice  Redbury furnace system right now  see good okay mutters there they go now  the fun begins I only have one rudder if  I lose it I can't steer the boat  this isn't the normal world this is  Antarctica and we have to do dangerous  things the overriding pressure on my  shoulders is fulfilling that mission to  resupply an article  now we look in to public faith that the  winner  I mean what's good down here all right  just keep it here put the engines in 30  minutes standby got a big workout back  here